we are getting closer and closer to what
we think will be an announcement of a
new Stargate franchise and we're getting
some very interesting rumors around who
might actually make the TV show welcome
to Sidetrack your Sci-Fi TV and movie
channel
[Music]
so I'm not going to mess around I'm
going to get straight into this one of
the big names that a very close friend
of the channel has been suggesting might
actually be involved in the new Stargate
franchise movie and TV series is a man
named Gary Barber now this guy actually
is the CEO currently of spyglass media
and Lantern entertainment it would be
Lantern entertainment potentially that
are actually going to be involved in
making the TV show but why is Gary
Barber such an interesting name well
he's well known to the employees of MGM
because he was actually their CAO until
2018.
now that ended up triggering quite a lot
of bad blood and in 2022 MGM had to pay
him a compensation settlement of
260 million dollars
so Gary Barber has got a few quid the
reason why that happened was because he
was basically fired but only five months
after signing a brand new contract he
was the CEO of MGM for quite a long time
he may be a big fan of Stargate for all
we know but why would MGM do this if
they fired the guy only a few years ago
and had to pay him 260 million dollars
well we don't know necessarily but
actually Spyglass media is partly owned
by Warner Brothers now this could be an
indication that perhaps Warner Brothers
are going to be involved in the
production of Stargate maybe they're
going to be the big production partner
that Amazon are looking for and if that
is the case then maybe they're looking
at Gary Barber as somebody that knows
MGM and actually is part of already a
group that could produce this so they
would have the production company the
Warner Brothers company and then they
would potentially have as well the
actual boots on the ground production
company in Lantern also remembering
though that if there is bad blood
between MGM and Gary Barber Amazon the
new owners might not give a crap so in
that case this is an interesting rumor
that's going around and even though it
seems unlikely because of the bad blood
in the history remember that the Amazon
are in charge maybe this is a deal
that's going to happen the other big
name is one that you'll know if you're a
big fan of the expanse now we already
know that it looks like Mark Fergus and
his team over at penguin and the Parker
are hopefully going to be doing the
development work for the Stargate
franchise they're going to be writing
the scripts Etc
this is a job they did for the expanse
for many years and I would argue very
successfully
but now in Shankar was actually the
showrunner of the expanse he was the
manager he was the guy in charge he
wrote several episodes for it as well
his name is now being potentially
rumored as somebody that could be coming
in to support penguin and Parker and to
once again act as showrunner for
Stargate why is this rumored well
according to a couple of my sources over
MGM he had actually had a meeting with
an executive over at marketing and the
vice president of development at MGM
that meeting apparently was for an
undisclosed project a MGM that's in
development now there aren't many
projects that actually he could
potentially be involved with and
considering man Shankar's vast sci-fi
experience he was a science advisor at
Star Trek the Next Generation Deep Space
Nine he wrote several episodes of TNG
Deep Space Nine and at least one of
Voyager he was the producer and writer
for the outer limits for several years
obviously there's the expanse he was an
executive producer and wrote several
episodes for Farscape he worked on
SeaQuest Grimm CSI to be honest
and most recently For All Mankind so we
can really assume that whatever this
undisclosed project in development is it
will be science fiction now we only know
of two major projects right now that are
actually in development now I've been
telling you that Stargate has been in
early stages of development for quite
some time now and that that snowball is
gathering pace and getting bigger and
bigger as we get towards that
announcement date
but there is another sci-fi project in
development We Believe at MGM thanks to
the deadline article a few weeks ago
that is RoboCop now to me it would seem
more likely than Aaron Shankar is in
there to talk about Stargate if it is
then true that Mark Fergus hawkos beaten
the team at penguin and Parker are
actually involved like we believe they
are now we know that negotiations with
Amazon were going on with penguin and
Parker over the Stargate franchise in
the room to Christmas but that those
negotiations have stalled we haven't
been able to hear I've not been able to
get anything from my sources since so we
don't know if there's been further
conversations or not but if there have
been or if at least unofficially there
have been and Mark Fergus has said look
talk to naren he knows how to do this
type of thing he knows how to showrun
this type of thing and he knows how to
keep this kind of thing grounded
then perhaps that's what they were
talking about now again we are talking
about rumor here we're talking about
speculation but it's all speculation and
rumor that do hook together
now I personally believe the Penguin and
a Parker will be involved in Stargate if
Sony are the primary production company
penguin and Parker and Sony are already
working together on gods of War and Sony
has a good working relationship with
Amazon but MGM has a really good working
relationship with Warner Brothers and
several deals for movies like The Rocky
Creed series recently
so it would make more sense to me if
actually it was going to be Lantern or
part of the Spyglass Media Group that
we're going to take the lead for the
Stargate franchise if MGM actually agree
for Warner Brothers to be the main
production partner this main production
partner deal is vitalo because Amazon
and MGM downtown Studios so they've got
to partner with somebody that does
let's hope that these deals are actually
secretly further along than we believe
and we are going to be getting the
announcement at San Diego Comic-Con in
just what six weeks but guys again to
the comments and tell me what you think
I would love to know what your opinion
is on this production partner problem
should it be Sony or should it be Warner
Brothers or actually doesn't it matter
because at the end of the day it's
whoever's developing the project that's
more important the Warner Brothers of
Sony production partnership is really
just Studio space however they will be
coming in they will be paying money
towards a project and they will be a
partner so they will have at least some
influence tell me exactly what you think
get into the comments if you are new to
the Channel please like subscribe hit
that Bell notification it really helps
us out and you'll never miss any of our
new videos also you can go to
patreon.com forward slash Sidetrack
where most of our new videos go first
and you can get to see them first for a
small contribution each month that
really supports the channel
as always guys please stay safe
looking forward to Stargate and I'll see
you soon
[Music]